tributes pouring in from all over for
the victims of Monday night's deadly
attack outside of ariana grande's
concert in Manchester England all we
know is the tragic news that there are
multiple fatalities and many injuries it
shocks me every time we hear this sort
of news that attacks like this can
happen but especially when there will be
so many children at this concert tonight
James Corden and the voices Carson Daly
took moments at the top of their shows
our hearts go out to the people in
Manchester England at the ariana grande
concert where an incident has occurred
lives have been lost and many hurt you
are in our thoughts and prayers tonight
we're thinking about you
then Katy Perry opening up to Elvis
Duran in New York Tuesday morning
I just feel devastated yeah yeah I think
like the greatest thing that we can do
now is just unite as people as like fan
bases all of it you know and in France
celebrities at the Cannes Film Festival
taking a moment of silence and sending
their thoughts and prayers to all of
those affected I'm terrified I don't
know what to say to my daughter again I
gotta eat her favorite singer if it was
in London this concept my daughter would
have been in that concert she would have
been there and it's a completely like
this is one of the reasons why I have
not slept so do I have a message no I
haven't processed it I don't even know
how to file I don't know where to begin
it's just despicable my heart goes I
take every single person is affected by
what happened last night and sorrow
I mean I don't have the words for it I
just have the absolute it's devastating
devastating and for the families that
are going through this now this is it's
not even to be discussed it's just to be
pray for them
you